ledit deux reprises sous les chapeaux de
roue pour les commerçants de fort de
france dans ce bazar il ya forcément un
peu d'appréhension je sais on attend la
réaction des clients on attend
à la suite on a mis des barrières de
l'ami des discussions par terre l'un des
maîtres et on nous la misère à la colle
tout ça un peu plus loin
là c'est un vendeur de petits gâteaux
qui jubilent oh là là je suis content
que le site serait oui oui j'ai enfin
monsieur
et puis bien qu'ils viennent acheter et
d'empêcher ces au top
derrière ce vendeur de pâtisseries une
queue incroyablement longue devant cette
enseigne une queue qui surprend même le
gérant
comme vous pouvez le constater il ya
beaucoup de monde qui attend donc on va
essayer de gérer au mieux
apparemment les dépenses sociales sont
pas trop respecté j'ai l'impression
qu'on va nous gérer à l'intérieur du
magasin maintenant nous allons rayon
mercerie uniquement les élastiques la
chose rare ces temps-ci je voyais qu'on
fait confectionner quelques mains en ce
jour de reprise la question sanitaire
est sur toutes les lèvres et des mesures
ont été prises par exemple dans ce
magasin de chaussures quand une paire de
chaussures sera essayé par quelqu'un par
exemple pour les changes qui va me
ramener quelque chose elle va rester
dans un va rester au dépôt on va
désinfecter avec un produit comme par
exemple pour les chaussures de bowlings
et on va aussi on à disposition des
chaussettes à usage unique
voici les chaussettes un visage uni la
cliente essaye d'accord dès qu'ils
terminent des essayages elle mettra en
gérant à la poubelle directeur on le
prêt-à-porter des mesures ont été prises
également on y sert qu'une fois on est
satisfait on repart avec le produit
ce n'est pas le cas le vêtement est
alors bien confinement pendant 48 heures
tout le textile ces 48 heures quand une
certaine température le oui oui
vie manifestement mal au niveau du
climat dont 48 heures me semble
raisonnable puisque trop d'humidité à
sec le virus ne tient pas sur le textile
en vérité commerçants et clients
s'observeront surtout en cette semaine
de reprise pour ensuite mener quelques
réajustements s'il le faut